there's also an argument to be made that
maintenance costs are necessary to keep
projects alive and pass them down from
generation to generation
the ise grand shrine is a shinto shrine
in japan that's torn down
and rebuilt every 20 years a practice
that's continued for more than 1200
years now
this practice of tearing down and
rebuilding serves a real purpose
which is not only to keep the shrine
looking fresh and new but also to pass
down the techniques of construction to
future generations
similarly software requires tearing down
and reconstruction to keep the tradition
of building alive
fergus henderson is a long-time software
engineer at google who once wrote about
google's internal processes
and according to fergus most software at
google gets rewritten every few years
he gave a few reasons for this the first
being that product requirements change
to keep up with modern technology and
changing user preferences
but he also points out that rewriting
software has positive benefits for their
organization
like trimming down unnecessary code
complexity as well as transferring
knowledge and a sense of ownership to
newer team members
so there are a lot of good reasons why
software is never done
like the easy grand shrine it's a
process that never ends and one that
involves passing knowledge from one
generation to another
despite its challenges software
maintenance shouldn't be considered a
problem per se
it's just a part of the ecological life
cycle